The Joe Rogan experience.
I've been coming out as transgender.
When you're straight,
I'm straight transgendered,
so I fancy women's.
I'm,
I want to be lesbian.
So if you come out you could stay in the closet and I look down the millennia.
If we go back to the ancient Egyptians and further,
there's probably a lot of guys said,
I don't have to tell anyone about this.
I just,
I fancy women.
I'll just go with it.
I just won't mention this kind of feelings in my head and I thought I should
mention it because if people shout and scream at me in the streets,
I will,
I will fight that.
At least verbally fight that.
Or you know,
if they start going through,
I have had one fight in the streets and I landed one punch.
I,
yeah,
I taught myself to geography on the streets because of this.
Yeah.
The guy was,
was just giving me,
Ooh,
Tracey,
oh,
what are they all dressed up?
And,
and I,
and I was,
I've been a street performer for four years.
It common garden.
So I was living on the street,
you know,
and living,
I was working on the streets and you know,
just knew a lot of people going around and just said,
man,
you don't have to be like this.
We can all the space enough for everyone live and let live kept giving me stuff.
It was a bit drunk,
Arista.
So he was just going to stay on that wicked keep saying and I said just chill
out,
chill out.
And then the third time I just said,
oh just fuck off.
And I went,
no I am,
I am loaded load of swear words on him.
And then he swung for me,
which was the handy thing cause that came up in court and then I swung back and
I landed one punch,
which I was pleased but and I was doing the wipe on wipe off stuff.
I was doing this,
you're blocking.
Yeah,
from the Jujitsu.
I taught myself Jujitsu form a book.
If you could believe that,
which you know,
you'll get these books with the different moves and then you can't teach
yourself that.
But I did Julia when I was six actually as well.
So I liked the idea of doing these things,
but I felt Jew there was always at the bigger kid,
you all get in pajamas and the bigger kit just throws you around a bit.
I can never quite get the hanger.
I couldn't throw the bigger kids.
I could do it now,
but I've never,
anyway,
yeah,
this is a fantastic video online of a very old judo expert in,
I think he's in his seventies or his eighties and he's working out with these
young men and you see his mastery of judo as these young,
powerful men try to manipulate him and throw him around and he effortlessly
watch this,
this old man and he see him.
He's very,
very old and he's throwing these guys around me as a martial arts expert.
These,
these men are not doing this willingly.
This is legitimate.
Like even that guy tries to throw him and this is a black belt who's trying to
throw him,
but he's so good and his,
his use of balance and leverage is so amazing.
He just knows where to be.
Like see how,
yeah,
yeah.
That just throws himself into a perfect position I made.
It's really stunning to watch.
And this looks like it was from the fifties or something like that cause it's
really old.
But yet as it say,
just has 75 year old judo master.
I mean this is an old man and the,
the young man is much larger than him.
Significantly like 25% larger than him.
At least.
Maybe even look up.
He looks at,
he's twice as big as him and he throw this old man.
It's really amazing.
Juno was a beautiful art.
Oh,
he's getting more and more full on these guys.
I gotta get this.
He's trying,
I mean he knows that this guy is a master,
but it's just look at that like it's incredible.
I mean,
the way that guy's body can toss these people through the air and yet they,
they are helpless.
They can't do anything to him that way.
That look at that boom.
Three times,
75 years old.
I mean,
that hurts my hips.
Just looking at that you,
you can have many different martial arts than you.
Yeah.
Which ones you Jujitsu and striking martial arts.
My background was in striking,
which is in taekwondo and then eventually kickboxing and Muay Thai.
And then I got really into Jujitsu when I got older.
And what on Jujitsu's,
what's the difference from Jujitsu is a grappling tall,
her choking people.
It's like you,
it's not throws like judo.
There are throws in Jujitsu,
but there it really comes from judo.
It comes from the ground fighting aspect of Judah,
which was not as emphasized,
but the Brazilians really,
really emphasized it and sort of,
uh,
they,
they figured out what the best way for a smaller person defeat a larger persons
through leverage.
And Jujitsu is really the only martial art that I can think of that works like
you think of a martial art in a movie,
like in a Bruce Lee movie.
Like there's all these people and they were always bigger than Bruce Lee.
Bruce Lee fucked him all up.
But in the real world,
that doesn't usually work.
Like the bigger people have such a giant advantage when it comes to like
striking.
Like you know,
you're never going to see a like a heavyweight in the UFC.
A fight,
a bantamweight fight,
a person who has 135 pounds just wouldn't,
it's just too much of an advantage and Jujitsu,
it's legitimately possible for 140 pound man to strangle a 200 plus pound man
and do it relatively easily if they're talented.
I I saw a documentary on very slowly and he had the way of no way.
Yeah.
Which really appealed to me.
I mean it's like a philosophy,
quite a map from fighting philosophy but um,
to be so trained up in so many things that the,
they do not know what you're going to do.
And I kind of adopted that.
He had to overcome significant prejudice,
prejudice to adopt that perspective because when he was studying martial arts,
you were supposed to be loyal to your style.
So if you learn Kung Fu,
you were supposed to be a Kung Fu man for life.
Yup.
You weren't supposed to also dabble in boxing and wrestling and all these
different things that he wasn't interested in.
He was interested in taking what's useful from all different martial arts and
applying them.
So in a sense,
he was really the founder of mixed martial arts,
which you see today in the UK.
They have cage warriors and the u s is a UFC and you know,
there's this worldwide now the,
the art of mixed martial arts of putting all the different styles together and
you can do whatever you want within the rules.
Now.
I liked the attitude of that.
I still have a life attitude though.
I mean there's obviously the fighting attitude of it and then there's the life
attitude of just be prepared for anything and everything.
Yeah.
And be,
and be like water.
Like that was his other thing.
Yeah.
Just to go around things,
move through things.
Yeah.
Don't,
don't head butt things.
Figure out what's the best way,
what is the,
what's the best,
best path.
Yeah.
You know?
I just,
um,
I haven't
learned.
When I said I think I'm waiting for someone to give me a really hard time.
Then I say,
now I am checking in and I am learning in my shot.
[inaudible].